How do my
teeth look?
Pretty good?
Okay great.
Fluoride in the water might be helping that,
but it might also be doing other things.
Fluorine is the 13th most abundant element
on the planet.
It's in seawater, foods like fish, tea and
gelatin contain it, and it's a naturally occurring
substance in minerals -- that is to say, IT'S
IN ALL THE ROCKS, because it's everywhere,
fluorine is washed into the water supply during
erosion.
Fluoride is just fluorine with an extra electron,
and when we see it in toothpaste, food or
drinking water, it's actually sodium fluoride,
or in our bodies it's calcium fluoride.
In the 1940s, scientists found that people
living near natural water sources with 1 part
per million of fluoride had fewer cavities.
So, they decided to add fluoride up to that
concentration to reduce cavities for everyone.
Unsurprisingly, controversy ensued.
Today, two-thirds of Americans have fluoridated
public water, but studies have thrown into
question the benefit of water-borne fluoride
compared to topical fluoride… or toothpaste
with fluoride.
A study of 23,000 skeletons from medieval
archaeological sites found people who live
near the coast and consumed fluoride-rich
fish had fewer cavities.
Another CDC study compared kids in the late-60s
to kids from the early 90s, and found a 68
percent drop in cavities.
Though this could be due to fluoride toothpaste,
not fluoridation as communities without fluoridation
also saw a decrease.
In the right concentrations -- that is, point-8
to 1.2 parts per million -- fluoride reduces
tooth enamel solubility during its formation,
helping it solidify and form teeth that are
more resistant to bacterial attack.
After the enamel is formed, fluoride helps
prevent bacteria from producing acid that
causes tooth decay.
Of course, higher concentrations of fluoride
can cause pitting in teeth, decay, and major
health problems.
Anything over 1.5 ppm can cause tooth decay,
and 3 to 6 ppm can cause skeletal problems.
And though there are some Chinese studies
correlating high fluoride with IQ problems,
no US city is even close to the 4 ppm EPA
limit.
Whether it’s cool to add fluoride to the
water is still a political and social point
of contention.
From a healthcare perspective, if we want
our teeth to last, we've gotta keep the enamel
free of harmful bacterial deposits - which
fluoride does.
Enamel, the outermost layer of the tooth,
is the toughest stuff the body can make, but
it can't repair itself.
It needs help.
Whether it belongs in the drinking water is
a complicated question, because for those
of us who didn't grow up with municipal drinking
water, like me, we HAD it in our well water
because the EARTH put it there.
Municipal sources get it as an odourless and
tasteless byproduct of phosphate fertilizers
that makes no perceptible change to the water,
according to the World Health Organization.
The WHO also recommends community water fluoridation
as the "most effective public health measure
for the prevention of dental decay."
Countries and states seem to be on board with
fluoridation until someone finds damning evidence
they shouldn’t be, which, in 70 years, no
one has yet found.
So, for the moment, water fluoridation is
still a thing, but what do you think about
it?
Do you care?